All right. So good afternoon, everyone.
Day before 2 p.m.
And you're all here with,
I was, I'm glad to see the presence,
the room.
Um,
my name is Ayan Data. I'm from Tara Consultancy
Services. I had the cloud Solutions,
and I'm privileged to introduce
two of our eminent speaker today
afternoon, uh, Shibu, our account
director for United Airlines,
and Sean, managing director, crew,
uh, modernization.
I, I'm not going to take much time. It's just
that
I will hand it over to Shubu to introduce
the program.
Uh, this is where
we wanted to highlight.
In the next one hour, how
the partnership, a three-way partnership
of TCS.
United and AWS
came together.
To display a real
business modernization, right? We always talk
about technology modernization. You'll see that
how a business is impacted, a
process is reimagined.
And with the help of technology,
and 3, the customer.
The the technology provider and
a service provider hand in hand came
together to make that happen, right? With
further ado,
I'll just ask Subu to introduce the
program. Thank
you. Good afternoon, everyone.
So my name is, uh, Subramanian Kussubu.
So I'm the account director for United Airlines, part
of, uh, TCS, uh, Travel,
Transportation and Hospitality
North America unit.
So I'm privileged to have, uh, Sean Carson here, uh,
to talk about some of the work we did in crew,
a little bit more deeper on some of the challenges, some
of the best things we did, and how we went,
uh, through this whole journey and how it
has helped, uh.
Uh, United to deliver business
value to their end customers, right?
Uh, TCSN United go a very long
way, uh, with over
20 years of togetherness,
uh, we have worked together in multiple
transformation programs
delivering, uh, business value to, uh, customers.
The strength of our partnership always relied
on our ability to leverage,
uh, domain expertise,
uh, business, uh, knowledge, contextual
knowledge. Uh, innovation
and, uh,
uh, the ability to, uh, do all
the things right at first, actually, right, those are
the key elements which has actually driven
us to partner and to deliver value to
the, uh, to United and to their,
uh, business as well, right?
Uh, with that, uh, you know, uh,
I would go a little bit more on the crew
side of the world
where, uh, TCS and United has been working
together for almost the last 10 years,
especially in the last 5 years there has been an aggressive
transformation approach that we have adopted together.
Along with the help of AWS,
uh, to see how we can better deliver business
value, uh, to the end customer,
uh, with that, uh, you know, we took a lot of, uh,
efforts and steps towards, uh, adopting
latest and greatest technology, including some
of the GEA aspects as well,
and also, uh,
uh, looked at, uh, industry best transformation
approaches to transform some of the elements of
crew and deliver value to the investors,
right? So with this, I have the privilege of
letting Shawn speak further,
a little bit more deep diving on, uh, some
of the work we did.
Uh,
here you go, Shawn.
Thank you. I think I'm good.
Thank you Subu. Thank you, Ian. Uh,
I am Sean Carson. I am one of the managing
directors in the digital technology division
at United Airlines. Uh, I
have
had the privilege of working in the
travel and hospitality industry for
roughly 30 years or so, 25 of
those at United.
Uh, an industry that has gone through
significant changes over that time period.
Uh, we've been a big part of it.
Uh, United's strategies and goals have been
innovation and, uh,
Uh, evolution, uh, and certainly
has, uh, changed the way that it tackles
industry problems.
Uh,
this program, I think is a good example of the type of
resiliency and innovation that
we've been encouraged to incorporate into our daily jobs
as we move forward, uh, and
transform the industry together.
I see a few industry colleagues out there, so
hopefully some of the
things that we covered today will resonate with some of you,
but it's, uh, uh, I'm happy to be here and share,
uh, some of the story with you guys today.
Uh, today we'll talk about a journey
that we have been on. We'll talk a little bit about United
and its background, where we are at,
uh, and where we are at,
uh, as an overall company.
Uh, the challenges of crew
operations, that's, uh, the centerpiece for
today's discussion, uh, and the way that we have
met and. Treated those challenges
as an opportunity to overcome, uh, and
the approach that we've taken, um, as well as
the partnership, uh, that was needed
in order to execute,
uh, on those, uh, uh, on
those changes
and then we'll talk a little bit about where we're headed, um, and if
we have a little bit of time, we'll leave a little bit of time for some
questions at the end.
First, a little bit about United. Uh,
United, uh, is the world's
largest airline by available
seat miles. That is just one of many
measures for how airlines measure
themselves. Uh, it is not the only one, but in this
measure, United is currently
leading the industry. We are proud to say.
Uh, this year we had a pretty important milestone.
We were able to eclipse, uh,
uh, operating more than 1000 aircraft.
That is a, uh, definitely a company first for us,
um, and it's certainly a statistic that we're proud of.
We service 380 destinations
worldwide,
uh, that is domestic and
international.
Uh, we have 7 domestic hubs,
um, in the US,
um, and at least one, you could
argue 2 international hubs.
Uh, we have more than 5000 daily
departures. Uh, that is a
milestone that has been growing
and is continuing to grow. It's a measure
of our
growth trajectory.
Uh, we flew nearly 175
million customers this year. Uh, that is a
big number, um, and certainly something that we are tracking
and certainly proud of.
Over 100,000 employees, uh,
I think we just eclipsed 110,000 this
year, as a matter of fact.
That is a number that grows, um, flows and
ebbs, uh, but it typically hovers around
that, a very large company.
Inside that company, we have more
than 18,000 pilots
and 28,000 flight attendants, and
this story is about them
and the, the teams that support those
organizations.
Uh, crew operations
services those two primary work groups.
So let's talk a little bit about what crew operations is.
Uh, our pilots and our flight attendants both
have,
uh, collective bargaining agreements, uh,
with United Airlines that govern their
work rules, and typically the way that
their flight schedules are organized, they
will bid based off of their seniority
and other work rules against their flight schedule,
uh, and then that
flight schedule is awarded on
a monthly basis, uh, based off of those
work rules, uh, that's applied to them,
uh, it becomes part of their, uh, strategy
and, um, is executed by it.
Uh, all goes well, they fly that
schedule and then we move on to the next month and the
process cycle is over again, but every month
there's some kind of disruption,
um, an unplanned disruption, and we have to.
Uh, adjust to the schedule. Uh,
typically this can be on a day to day basis
because of maybe a maintenance activity where we have
to pull an aircraft out of the, uh,
schedule and adjust things and make
adjustments to your flight schedule in order to still accommodate,
uh, passengers
on or close to, uh, your
flight schedule. If you've ever had a flight where your
flight adjusted by 15 minutes, typically that
was maybe the driver behind all of that.
Um, but with 7 domestic hubs and
most of the uh, the hubs in the US
are in
weather prone locations, uh,
uh, operational disruption is
not uncommon and so
what happens then is if we have to
cancel or reschedule,
uh, a flight in order to accommodate around a hurricane
or a
huge snowstorm in the south, uh, in
the northeast,
uh, we have to perform an irregular
operations activity.
Uh, that means that because of work rules associated
with the crew, that monthly flight schedule
gets disrupted,
um, and those, uh, flights become what we
call open time flights, um, or,
uh, part of a vast puzzle that needs
to be solved
with 7 flights with 7 hubs
in a complex interconnected series
of, uh, network and all of those passengers
to accommodate,
uh, it's a pretty complex puzzle to solve.
And there is a group, uh, there are 2 groups
at United that work on this puzzle every
day. They are called crew scheduling. One is
for the pilot side, the flight
ops team.
And one for the flight attendants, the
in-flight. They all have different and independent work
rules,
which means their teams need to understand those rules and
be able to solve that puzzle. Uh, it takes
about a year and a half in the,
uh, current structure to
hire a new employee into this
crew scheduling team,
um, and get them to a point where they are adept at being able to
solve this puzzle, um, in one of those er circumstances.
That creates a challenge and
it means that it is an area rife for
uh solutioning
um and technology tools and that is where we come into
play. So, uh,
crew ops is subject to several
challenges.
Now, the industry is, is,
has, has been around for quite a while
and some of our technology is quite aged.
Some of that technology is famously aged
and uh that means that what
we have right now, the primary system
that we had been using historically in
order to manage
our crew environment was um
a legacy mainframe application.
Uh, now, mainframe applications are very
Uh, solid and structured, but they can be constrained.
Uh, what that means is that as the ecosystem
around that environment evolves and changes,
uh, making adjustments to our
mainframe environment, uh, become more and more complicated,
and that can limit what we can do, uh,
around things like innovative changes around adopting,
uh, automation standards and things like that.
Uh, the industry,
particularly the cruise side, is subject to regulatory
disclosures. Uh, safety is something
all domestic airlines, all airlines worldwide
take extremely serious. Uh, it's an
area where we often
and famously indicate we do not compete.
Uh, we share information and strategies
around safety. All airlines do,
um, and a big part of that is disclosing regulatory
changes and making sure that we are connected. In
particular in the US, that means disclosing
data points to the FAA.
In aligning with some of the work rule strategies so
that they are clear that we are operating under their
guidelines.
Uh, our legacy systems, especially
some of our mainframe environments, means that the resources
available that know how to operate that environment,
um, are not as readily available as they used
to. Uh, some of the, the aging technologies
mean that we
finding resources, people that can manage
those activities,
uh, are, uh, fewer and farther,
uh, between to find.
And the resources themselves and the tooling
themselves, uh, as we grow, uh,
the system is quite,
uh, stable, but as we wanna integrate into,
uh, the broader path of the ecosystem,
uh, the, uh, the
available resources to be able to handle that become challenged.
We are subject to operational reliability, uh,
issues. Uh, it is not just weather events,
industry challenges,
uh, uh,
let's just say rub points that are part of our
integrated into our network strategy,
aging, uh, airports, um, and
staffing issues that are kind of beyond our control.
Uh, and then our utilization
for crew itself. We are in the middle of a very
large growth, uh, trajectory which we'll talk a
little bit about later on in the presentation,
uh, but it means that we're hiring significantly and
we need available staff in order to be able to handle
a growing network.
So being able to optimize our network, um, and
make sure that we're
taking advantage of the resources that we have in an optimized
way, um, is a big challenge for us.
Uh, when things go wrong, disruption
becomes a significant problem, and managing through
that and solving that puzzle, um, is a
keystone of what it is that we do.
And as you might imagine, when we build our
data structure, we build a little bit at a
time and the opportunity to become siloed,
uh, becomes significant.
Certainly as we moved into a much more analytics
focused age, uh.
Uh, bringing all that data together into a centralized
place, uh, has become a significant priority
and breaking down some of those four decade long,
uh, bad habits, um, is a big challenge.
Never let a challenge go to waste. So, uh,
United, uh, took a look at this environment
and many years ago, about 8 or 9 years
ago, uh, started to undertake a
transformation journey
to take a look at that environment, um, and
try to adjust and evolve
that environment as we went forward.
Uh
What you see here are just some of the core tenets that we leveraged
in order to uh try to set sail
um and set some some targets
and strategies.
Uh, first and foremost, building a system
that helps improve operational reliability
was one of the foremost pillars of what it is that we wanted to undertake
as we thought about transforming,
uh, the technology platform,
uh, things like, uh, getting proactive
with our crew scheduling teams in
order to be able to anticipate
and, um, uh.
Uh, position crew where they need to be, uh,
anticipating issues, um, and schedule adjustments
where possible,
became a big part of what it is that we, uh, wanted to
try to have the technology help enable.
So what if scenario building, uh, for
example, is a big part of our,
our, our platforming, uh, demands.
Uh, scheduler empowerment means
taking, uh, the information and
presenting it to the scheduler so that they have the
tools and means to be able to operate efficiently,
uh, creating a lot of decision support tools
and, um, making those easy to consume,
um, especially trying to breach that, uh, 18
month learning curve for new hires in order
to make the tools a lot more intuitive.
One of the, um, drawbacks of a mainframe
environment, once you learn it, it's a really powerful
tool, but it involves using.
Legacy green screen commands, things like that,
and it means that you really need to
operate within that modality.
Uh, ensuring that we are compliant
with all of our contract rules,
uh, and, uh,
the evolution of those contract rules every 4,
let's say every 4 to 6 years, uh, we go
through a new contract renewal with each of the,
uh, labor unions that we work with, uh, that govern
the flight attendants and the pilot groups.
That means that rules change. Um, in
fact, we just recently finished,
uh, an agreement,
uh, with the pilot union,
uh, about, about a year and a half ago or so, which
means we're on the eve of making more adjustments to
them. But,
um, coming off the heels of COVID, there were
significant adjustments that were related to,
uh, schedule enhancements, um, as
pilots wanted to
shift their mindset away from, um.
Compensation being their primary focus and
uh starting to balance our work-life balance. That was
a key change that happened and that had a direct
impact on some of the things that we needed to adjust
and be flexible on in our environment.
Uh, the employee experience is a big part of our
focus.
Legacy green screens are
reliable but not super great when it
comes to
work, uh, optimization. And
so our crew scheduling team had a lot to say
about the way that we tool things out
in order to make their jobs easier and more efficient.
And then above all making sure that we had a a
strategy to handle uh uh
a reduction in overall disruption
from a crew scheduling perspective that means avoiding
what we call secondary cancellations.
Um, a flight will cancel because of a weather event,
but if we can't re-crew uh the
flight that got displaced,
we can cause a secondary cancellation
uh as a result of that and avoiding those is
paramount to
the strategy behind this environment.
Our approach, uh, effectively
required a grounds up approach to the
entire environment. Our
platform itself, uh, our
mainframe environment,
monolithic, handled everything in
an independent way,
and so an opportunity to really break through
that, uh, paradigm and think through things
differently,
uh, was, uh, I think at the forefront of what we undertook.
Um, at the beginning, uh,
and at the, uh, the primary elements of
that was rethinking the platform itself.
Um, instead of
having a single monolithic platform,
instead breaking that model out, um,
so that we could
take the different elements of what make up crew
operations,
uh, pay structure, the scheduling elements,
things that are, uh, handing off data
to downstream consumers
or elements that are consuming, uh, data from upstream,
um, into compartmentalized subsections
so that if one area of the environment
went down or was challenged
because of latency or some other.
Maybe unexpected data problem,
um, it did not bring the entire environment down.
Um, the other, uh, opportunity
here is to, uh, take a look at our legality
rules. Uh, so this is a key part of the way
our environment operates.
Uh, today in our mainframe-based environment, or
I should say yesterday in our mainframe-based environment,
those rules were embedded,
um, there's one more element of the cobalt logic
that was, um,
driving the way that mainframe environment was built,
uh, which means changing those rules is
complex. So if we shift from.
A 5 hour shift um
opportunity to a 5.25 hour shift
opportunity and then going in and hard coding and coal
that change
instead shifting into a centralized,
uh, queriable,
uh, legalities engine, uh, became a
key part of our, uh, a central part
of our architecture standard.
And then, uh,
channeling the way that, uh, we think
through the the data structure itself, uh, became
a, a big part of our approach,
uh, shifting our entire environment into microservices
instead of funneling everything through single integrated
work cues,
really about trying to accelerate and speed, uh,
the nature of the way the environment itself operates.
Uh,
centering an environment around automation
and then building trust in that automation,
those are,
I, I would, I would characterize that as a people and a
process, uh, uh, a change in
addition to technology.
Um, it's not just about building tools that allow
automation, but we need to ensure that the people
that are using those tools are relying on that
automation and, um, uh, can support
it. Especially when we're talking about things
as personal as
um an individual crew member's schedule that
will influence
the most personal data point of all for them, which is
their pay. Um,
and most important of all,
United is in the middle of a massive growth cycle,
uh, a program that we call United Next,
uh, that is a program that involved, uh, purchasing
and growing,
uh, the, the fleet exponentially.
Uh, might be a little bit
optimistic to indicate a 100%, uh,
capacity increase, but that is our target
and, uh, what we are shooting for
in order to, uh, to truly grow the
airline into
Uh, uh, something unprecedented and
so that means having a system that can support
a 100%, uh,
increase. We have to make sure that the environment that we
build is futureproof for that,
um, it can handle, uh, the intake for all
the different, uh, crew members that are coming in.
But not just that,
the ecosystem around the environment is also evolving
and changing. The tools that other groups
are using,
including gathering crew information to be able to
make strategic decision,
those tools were evolving as well.
And so we need an environment that could align
with those types of uh uh changes
um so that we could continually provide
greater and greater data elements into those environments.
Our centralized
legality strategy where the query and
response strategy was a big part of that
plan, um, and is part of the execution of that plan.
As a result, uh, we ended up building a
platform and again we started
on the, um,
on-prem side. Uh, so this
journey goes back about 8 or 9 years or so before
United really got deep into, I'd say pivoting
into a cloud strategy.
Uh, the architecture underpinnings, I think, were
initiated many years back.
Um,
interactive channels for transactions
and monitoring.
Um, that different work groups can use
in order to be able to oversee,
um, and then introduce observability
objectives we were thinking about that, um,
even as we were starting the on-prem architecture
itself. Uh, we started to shift
into a, um, a multi-domain,
uh, integration strategy.
So that meant instead of having a single monolithic
application, breaking things up into sub-applications,
um,
that sounds inefficient, but the way
crew operations work,
we don't need to have everything inside a single application. We
began to kind of challenge those mores a little bit,
um, and build bespoke tools that were
designed to be a little bit more customized for
specific applications. Crew scheduling needs
are different than what the
Uh, the pay team needs in order to be able to evaluate
and, and, um, audit the, the pay cycle
which is also on a monthly cycle.
Uh, the validation engine and
establishing that and then building the
ability to be able to evolve and adjust
that validation engine.
Our legality rules themselves, uh,
became a key part, uh, uh, of our
program. We didn't just centralize
that, we had to build a, uh, platform
that could handle millions of transactions.
Um, that's the area that I think
we'll experience the most growth, especially over
the next 5 to 10 years as we continue to leverage
and evolve this platform.
More and more tools, both internal
and external, are going to query and respond
to challenge and understand
what a scenario is based off of,
uh, whether or not a crew member could
or should be able to fly on a given route.
Uh, we can use that internally for our own air ops
related management in order to try to think through different
scenarios
or external tools to say.
Hey, I wanna maybe make a
decision to cancel this flight,
but I don't know what that's gonna do to the crew team.
So now we can with this structure
begin to
um enhance those applications,
provide a system of record insights around what
might happen if they were to
make decision A instead of decision B, and
then we can begin to work really interoperably with
the other teams that are making joint decisions
around the way that we operate.
Uh, and then, uh,
um.
That is the, the starting point. Uh,
now, so the cloud journey became a
big part of the way that we executed on this
about 4 to 5 years ago or so,
United started to really pivot into,
uh, centralizing its long-term resiliency
plan, not just for crew,
uh, technology, uh, but for, um,
many of our tier 1 and tier 0
applications. Today, I believe something like 80
critical applications are on the
AWS platform, a significant
transformation journey that we have been on.
Uh, ADBS has become a big partner of ours,
um, as has TCS in order to help us,
uh, execute on at least the crew scheduling
plan. Uh,
once we started to select, uh, the cloud
migration
plan as part of our journey,
all kinds of long-term, uh, tooling
and strategies started to become, uh,
available to us to potentially, uh, leverage and move
forward, um, and a
big part of the, uh, transformation journey involves evaluating
those, uh, platform opportunities, picking the
right one for us, the one that meets our
specific servicing needs,
um, and moving us forward,
uh.
As a result,
our opportunity for increased compute power
has grown exponentially.
The way as we're transforming, we
can make a much more structured approach to the
way that we catalog and manage data,
certainly operating with that insider cloud
environment and matching that up against some of the
other partner systems that have also moved into that
same platform.
Uh, and
standardizing and modernizing the way that we
think about the platform,
uh, promote changes, um, and support those
changes long term.
Uh, today we have a much more resilient
application, um, as a result of this, uh, short
term decisions.
Uh, the environment itself, uh, becomes,
uh, a state of the art crew
scheduling application, uh, that
we are quite proud of. Uh, it is something that was built internally,
uh, through blood, sweat, toil, and tears,
and, uh, is a competitive
advantage for United now. It's, uh, I'd
say how we tend to think of this.
Crew disruption can be a very,
um.
Uh, visible disruption, um,
and, uh, it also can snowball and can
create lots of problems and becomes very visible to customers.
So being able to, to proudly articulate
and leverage these tools in order to be able to
reduce risk in the space,
um, is significantly important. It becomes significantly
important to continue to evolve for United.
Uh, central to all of that is our alerting
engine. Uh, those are using the, uh,
Uh, the legality rules in order to be able to
draw attention and provide
decision support, uh, uh,
mechanisms for our schedulers,
uh, that has now become a,
uh, centerpiece of the way that we, our, our
schedulers think of the, um,
application instead of simply, uh, trying
to look at the next flight to, uh, to resolve. They are
able to prioritize and evaluate
alerts based off of priority and,
uh, what is, what needs to be addressed now
versus first in, first out.
Uh, we have our centralized rules engine,
uh, that is now, uh,
platformed and ready for us to start, uh, building
automation, uh,
uh, strategies on top of. That is our current
plan, uh, and the
current slate of work that we are undertaking,
uh, for our business partners as we think about their
long-term roadmaps.
Cloud also offers a couple of different
options, uh, but probably the most important one
is it's, uh, auto scaling
capability.
Uh, we can scale on
on-prem and we can certainly scale even on
our mainframe-based environments, but there it's,
it's more costly. Um, you sort of have
to build a lot of extra space anticipating,
uh, uh, ebbs and flows,
uh, especially around irregular operations when
data flows tend to.
Start to spike, um, and, uh, the
processing needs increase.
One of the main advantages of cloud is to be able to
allow the platform itself to kind of evolve with,
um, uh, those data demands and
then pull back,
um, so that we're being a little bit more optimal
once we have Blue skies day, um, that is
definitely in place,
um, and it is a big part of an advantage that we are now
taking, uh, able to take advantage of.
Uh, and
I think when we were on our mainframe environment we were
able to enjoy platform stability,
but that's not the same thing as redundancy
and resiliency. As we grow the network,
uh, we stress that network and that
means that the systems that are kind of surrounding
our environment, our mainframe may be stable, but the
data feeding into it
or the consuming systems that are pulling data
out of it may not be quite as stable. And
so, uh, by being able to shift
to a more
data-focused resiliency strategy, we
can do things like park data.
Um, in a, uh, holding space and buffer
it so that we can create a much
more efficient recovery strategy for downstream
consumers if something goes wrong with the
way they're, uh, taking data into their environment.
If something happens upstream,
uh, we can be in a position where,
uh, we can.
Um, whole processing in a much
more structured fashion now,
um, and be able to integrate, um, and wait for those, the,
uh, the, the upstream data to catch up,
um, so that we don't lose,
uh, or have to throw away records, um, and
then do a bunch of manual work, uh, and spend a day
and a half trying to recover from, uh,
a one hour system outage, those types of things.
We are taking advantage of the, um,
automated, uh, disaster recovery
structure that comes along with cloud.
Um, and the more applications
that we move into the AWS cloud, the more we can take advantage
of that of automated recovery.
No, we didn't just
uh re-platform. This is not a lift
and shift strategy. We worked with our partners
in order to adjust, um, and
try to meet their needs as we evolved. Uh, we
completely revolutionized the front end screens,
um, and today we have 4
independent, uh, crew
applications that are all managed by different teams that
all integrate and combine with each other.
All of those monolithic, uh,
independent cues that all went through a single
independent queue have been broken down into more than 380
microsurfaces now.
That is probably the,
uh, the,
uh, the, the, the single most advantageous
change that we made.
In order to try to maintain resiliency,
one minor cue goes down. It won't clog
the pipeline, um, and prevent critical
data from flowing into our environment now,
and it'll buy us time, especially in a,
in a, uh, situation
where we can monitor and see a microservice is, uh,
struggling because of some unexpected data
condition, uh, to be able to recover and,
uh, quickly respond.
Um, overall,
um, the effort reduction for transactions,
um, has diminished significantly. This isn't,
um, a, uh, something our,
uh, resources, uh, have,
uh, specifically, uh,
uh, come to appreciate.
Uh, we are growing and so
our manpower demands have not lessened, uh,
but the work that they do and the, uh, the
ease with which they operate is much easier
now that they have
decision support tools that are
a lot more, uh, focused and, um, and
put together.
And uh on the data
uh front, we uh have been able
to centralize everything um and also take
advantage of a different uh
uh change that United has been putting in place
uh to centralize all of our data into a centralized
data hub.
That is not necessarily and only part of the
program that we have built,
but by restructuring the data, uh, itself,
um, and putting it into a position where it could be
integrated into a centralized data hub strategy,
we've been able to enable a much bigger enterprise
change, um, and then.
Be able to plug in an entire analytics
industry into
uh trying to take advantage of that data in order to
be able to create decision support tools to go even
beyond our
uh our system's capabilities.
Um, and then last but certainly not least,
uh, our training costs, uh,
have, uh, have gone down.
Not to mention our, uh, attrition rates.
Uh, so the system that we have today is more nimble.
It's easier to use, uh,
it's more intuitive and
more aligned, I think, with, um,
the types of tools that people are expecting when
they come to work at a modern company.
Uh, tools that allow mouse clicks
instead of, uh, memorizing,
um,
mainframe commands, uh, things like that,
um, and that is significantly, uh, reduced
and created new opportunities for training.
It still takes a while,
uh, to become an expert crew scheduler. You
still need to learn the puzzle and you need to understand the
network and the terminology and the impacts,
the fleet types and all of the rules that come along
with it. But we
can now compartmentalize roles, um,
and make it easier so that maybe your
initial role when you join the team is a,
uh, uh, less impactful
role so that you can learn the ropes, um, and not
create disruption and that team now
has a lot those teams have much more flexibility
in managing new hires.
So at the end of the day what we have is, I think an
environment that takes into account people process and
technology changes all at once.
Going forward, uh, so we have
a few.
We're we're nowhere near done.
This is a transformative journey. Transformation
is a journey, not a destination, um.
Probably don't need to tell you that, uh, that's uh
stands for itself.
The when we stop innovating, uh, we start stagnating.
So these are just a few of the thoughts
that we have um as we move forward and I can talk
a little bit about what some of the strategies are
to undertake these activities, but.
Uh, one thing we can do, we can transform
our environment now that we have a resilient
application, uh, that can, uh, integrate
with, uh, changes in a more efficient way
and the external applications that we're operating.
We can start to think about transforming the platform into
an intelligent workspace.
Uh, so what that means is, and
today the way our operating center works,
there is a central ops group, uh,
that manages the network schedule.
They themselves have to make decisions based off
of what crew are available,
uh, the maintenance schedule, and then the
ground handling operations that might be available,
all of which are mobilized resources
that make up important parts of our,
our fleet management and the way that we manage schedule
changes.
Uh, by
transforming the space we can feed
information into a centralized
tooling strategy in a much more efficient
manner and begin to get
predictive analytics,
uh, and, um, other tools
embedded into those spaces so that all
of those teams can begin to work together in a much more efficient
manner.
That is probably the most exciting part of what we've
done here by enabling
and sort of, um, breaking the shack levels
or oral mainframe environment.
We can now
start thinking about taking this data and um
connecting it to
uh some of the AI tools that we have in order to be able
to proceed.
Um, we will talk a little bit more about the TCS partnership
shortly, but one of the areas that we've been looking
at with them.
TCS has a tool called Mastercraft.
This is an embedded platform that they have
inside their environment.
Um, that is used to drive
a variety of, um, AI
related solutions.
Uh, it's got an embedded large language
model and, uh, can also be connected
to a variety of applications.
We've started with some proof of concept evaluations
and what we would like to do with those tools,
um, is to take a look at some of
the challenges that we have in this space and see if we
can plug in and embed
a, uh, integrated,
um, AI tool into the space so that we
can. Start to have the AI environment,
uh, start making decisions for us
and then also use those tools in order to evaluate
the requirements that we have in order
to facilitate making some of those adjustments
as we go forward.
Those types of possibilities were not
possible, uh, five years ago when we were
talking about leveraging a,
um,
uh, a centralized environment
on a legacy platform.
Uh, observability
and, uh, evaluation,
uh, and reliability is a big part of
United's current focus and, and will
continue to be a part of that focus.
Um, establishing concepts like, uh,
creating a digital twin.
Now this is an interesting concept, I think. Um, it's
not just about platform transformation or creating
tools that technology resources can use
in order to be able to evaluate.
The health um um of the application
itself and maybe proactively get in front of preventing
issues although
this type of thing will help with that.
It also is, I think, a transformative change
for the, um, schedulers themselves, the people
that are using the platform.
They will eventually
shift away from transactional based
processing, thinking about how do I repair this flight.
We'll move in the direction of letting the
tool take care of that instead.
And they will instead shift more towards a holistic
view and so
a digital twin will allow our resources
to take a broad look at the spectrum,
think about how crew fits into a broader ecosystem,
and then begin to partner with their business teams in order
to be able to make
strategic decisions.
There are certain things that are always going to be, uh, unanticipated
changes that are going to come in.
Uh, some route will close,
uh, because of a.
Political, uh, circumstance or
an unprecedented change that was just
not anticipated related to
something like a COVID event or a crowd strike event,
we're going to need, uh, people in humans
in the loop
in order to be able to, uh, aggregate
those, uh, decision trees into
an automated solution
and if we can start to think differently, um,
and bring our tools up a level and
have the people think differently about the way that they're thinking about their
ecosystem.
They can be a lot more effective and then respond
much more quickly and effectively against those
types of um those types of events that
that occur. Uh,
and then, um.
Probably one of the most exciting changes, uh,
big, uh, adjustment, I think
on the analytics space, um, but
thinking through agentic AI.
Uh, Agentech AI is,
uh.
You know, I think a buzzword, uh, thrown around,
um, it's, uh, a, um, aspirational
goal, uh, but if you think about what
crew scheduling is, um, and what its
operation is, it's a series of complex
decisions. It's not one giant decision, it's
a, a subseries of of
repeatable but integrated tasks
that require a little bit more than just predictive
decision tree making.
Um, but need to aggregate information
from other sources. It is an ideal platform,
uh, for building an agentic AI, but it is
a complicated
execution. And so
that is where we're turning attention next. So we're trying to
think about innovative ways to, to think through identifying
commonality points,
look for automation potential,
um, and, um.
Execute on trying to uh build
a strategy where we
uh can have the uh
machine learning take care of the decision tree for us
rather than rely on human capital.
If we can do that, we really free ourselves,
I think from the uh the confines of,
uh, transaction-based processing,
um, shift people into a different mindset where they're trying
to just make that,
uh, system work better
by injecting more and more insight into
the decisions that, uh, the machines themselves are
making so.
That is where we will take the space next, um,
especially now that the core platforming is in place,
um, and as
AI tooling evolves and partners
like AWS and TCS begin continue to evolve
their platforms, United will continue to take advantage
of the expertise that comes from,
from those spaces.
Um, and that takes me a little bit to the partnership model.
Um, so I wanna talk a little bit about this, um.
United is an expert in um
airline management, right? We are a,
we're, you can argue we're
maybe not just one company but a host
of different companies. We're a digital technology
company. We're a catering services
organization. We're a maintenance company.
We are an airline, uh,
we are a
uh crew management, uh,
organization. All of these things require disparate
and
distributed,
um, expertise.
Uh, I think somebody told me this the other day,
it takes something like 30,000
applications to get a passenger from the point where they
purchase
a ticket
to the part where they arrive at their destination and take their
bag off of the baggage carousel. Um,
that is a lot of technology
that's standing between you and your destination.
Uh, it is a really complicated, uh, puzzle to
solve, and it's a really exciting industry to be a part of.
How do we do it? We do not do it alone. Uh,
and so what we have found, and I think that this
program is a really good example of that.
Uh, we've been able to take advantage,
um, of, uh, some really strong partners.
Um, we see the
implementation in particular of this
program as a,
um, example of the success that can come when you
take a core domain based
group that has its own,
um, capability set in United
leverage a powerhouse
delivery partner
like TCS that leverages an on and
offshore,
uh, flexible delivery model.
Um, and then marry that up against a, uh, best
in class platform that is also
replete with its own expertise
that we can take advantage of
for innovative changes and platforming tools
like AWS. Uh, all three
of those,
uh, those groups
are, I think, uh, paramount to the success
of being able to,
to truly take an indus uh, an industry platform,
uh, that goes back maybe 4 decades and transform
it. This pattern you are seeing,
um.
Repeated elsewhere at United, we have other mainframe
applications.
We have other, uh, challenges to solve
and, uh,
simply leaning in on this model um has yielded
really great results and enabled for us
to accelerate our cloud migration journey.
It doesn't come for free.
Uh, there is a cost, uh,
uh, for partnership,
you get out of a partnership what you put into it,
and I think
really thinking through how we work with
these partners and engage with them,
uh, is what's paid, is what's paid dividends.
We have to change our own,
uh, strategies for how we think about our
technology, break through our own silos, and challenge
our own,
uh, notions in order to be able to accept insights.
What I think I really like about this model.
If we, we have built a model where we,
uh, try to make sure that everybody has a voice, all
three, parties, all three
partners,
uh, and
by creating an inclusive environment where
everybody has a chance to, to bring in their,
their insight,
the opportunity and chance to have somebody who maybe can
bring us all forward becomes much greater, and that
is, I, I think a pattern that has emerged, especially
as we, um, uh, reached
challenges.
TCS and their expertise became, uh, an
important partner of ours as we worked through.
Critical deadlines and
addressing unexpected
challenges as business partners' needs
shifted over time.
Um, and we certainly leveraged AWS,
um, and, um, not just their domain
experience through their techno account,
technical account managers, uh, that were part
of our day to day operations,
uh, but their own professional services
organization to be able to tool up, uh, incremental expertise.
United also has a, a structured
series of enterprise teams that has been growing
and, uh, in particular, I'd
say in the last couple of years with some.
Uh, recent leadership adjustments has created
a significant platform for domain experience.
So we can take that expertise from, uh, AWS,
learn from it, and then capitalize on it and distribute
it. I'm gonna repeat those patterns for
other, uh, teams that are maybe implementing similar
technologies.
Uh, at the end of the day, what
we have is a platform that, uh, yields
significantly increased resiliency,
um, and, uh, has, um, paved
the way for, uh, future opportunities.
Uh, real pleasure to be with you today. Uh,
we do have a little bit of time for some
questions. Uh, I think I'm told we can,
uh, meet over here if you would like to
probe a little bit deeper on anything that we've done today, we
will make ourselves available and, uh, stay connected
on the,
uh, fringes here so that we can talk to you a little bit more about the
solution that we've put together.
Um, hope you're enjoying the conference
and I look forward to seeing you, uh,
in future years where we, uh, maybe evolve
the platform to the next layer, uh, of delivery.
Thank you for your time.